good morning john about a year ago i had
an idea and i want to walk you through a
little bit of the process of where this
idea came from i'm obviously in the
business of e-commerce and so i spent a
lot of time like looking
at the landscape and thinking about it
and it's boring it's not boring actually
so it turns out that there's a lot of
products that people are just going to
need
in their lives and manufacturing high
quality
products is getting easier so you have a
lot of companies
that have very like functionally similar
products that are differentiating
themselves
on their story but oftentimes and i'm
not trying to make any enemies here
these stories are pretty thin facades
over what are very similar or sometimes
actually literally identical products
and so everybody in this business is
talking about how the only important
thing
is your story and so i'm thinking like
what's the best
story everybody's trying to figure out
what the best story is but there's one
thing
that they won't really compromise on
which is that ultimately the company
needs to make money and i'm like
does it because if you're going to have
a company that sells stuff people need
and it's fairly easy to make this stuff
then why not just have a company that
does that but then gives all the money
away
this isn't a new idea back in the 80s
paul newman american
amazingly attractive man and also very
talented
sweet guy he like made salad dressings
for fun and then he was like well i
don't want to make money
but i do want to make salad dressing and
so he created newman's own with some
friends of course and now there's this
like fairly major food brand that gives
all of its profit to charity and it's
been around
for like 40 years now they've given away
half a billion
dollars i'm like super obsessed with
their story there's actually a bunch of
ways that giving all your profit away
makes a company harder to run i think
maybe obviously but maybe some
not so obvious reasons as well but there
are also ways that it makes it easy and
i think if everything's going to be
about story
then let's make this story actually good
so this week john and i are launching
the awesome socks club it's a sock
subscription
every month of 2021 you're going to get
a different pair of socks delivered to
you
and every one of those is going to be
designed by a different independent
artist that we found on the internet
we've got more than two pairs designed
but we're just showing the first two
because part of the joy of this for me
anyway has been being surprised by what
our designers have come up with
they look great they feel great shipping
is free everywhere that has an address
and yes
100 of the profit goes to charity right
now it's going to decrease maternal and
child mortality in sierra leone but
we hope maybe as this thing grows that
it will be able to do
more good in more places and more ways
it's already doing extremely well it
launched on
monday we've got thousands of people
signed up already it's very exciting
i did a bunch of brand deals with
tick-tockers which has been amazing
and very weird you also might hear ads
for it on some of your favorite podcasts
like 99 invisible and the try guys
tripod this is definitely the start of a
great sock subscription club like
already it is that but i'm hoping maybe
it can be the start of something even
bigger than that so on this black friday
if you'd like to give a gift to yourself
once a month for all of 2021
you can sign up at awesomesocks.club
vlogbrothers or you can give it as a
gift to someone else or you can ask
somebody
to give it to you as a gift but you have
to sign up before december 11th because
that's when we close the subscription
down this way we know how many socks we
should manufacture and there's no waste
and also if you want to have a more
robust picture of what the uh the sort
of commerce landscape of nerdfighteria
looks like this season we're also gonna
have a charity calendar that's coming
out
fairly soon it's just not quite ready
yet i'm gonna be making a video about
this
delightfully creepy christmas story that
i
discovered on the internet i didn't
write it or illustrate it but i wanted
to collaborate with the artist to make a
video about it and
the artist will be selling that i just
loved it and i wanted more people to
know about it my publisher has put an
absolutely remarkable thing on sale in
ebook format for three dollars so if you
wanted to give that a try
now is the time also in general advice
from somebody who runs an e-commerce
company if you're buying stuff
uh online this christmas season order it
right now because
the shipping infrastructure of this
country is going is like already very
at its limit links for awesome socks
club in the doobly-doo john
i'll see you on tuesday